well guys it's finally that time of year
again where I can talk about my least
favorite films of the year and this is a
lot of fun I love making these videos
and there's going to be films here that
you guys are going to disagree with and
others where you're like why isn't that
there and why is that there and why is
this above this one and why is this in
that and I liked that movie and I don't
you're too hard on that one Chris and
that's fine I mean everyone has
different opinions so I'd like to know
what are some of you guys were spics
make a video response comment below and
let me know how you feel about it but
let's get started right off the bat I
have a few of what I like to call this
honorable mentions films that didn't
quite make the list but still you just
kind of want to have them there but
they're not quite there because there
were ten others that were worse than
these films my first dishonorable
mention is Twilight Breaking Dawn Part
two I don't really understand why people
thought this movie was in any way better
than the others there's like a 15 minute
fight scene in it that was cool but it
was a complete bait-and-switch it didn't
add anything to the story it was just
kind of there to show some heads being
ripped off everything else about the
movie was exactly like the others my
second dishonorable mention is chernobyl
Diaries Wow what a horrible horror film
complete found-footage garbage just it
went nowhere the performances were awful
and it had nothing to offer and my third
and final dishonorable mention is the
lucky one with Zac Efron the movie in
which he walks across the entire United
States with a dog in the same pair of
clothes and doesn't have a scratch on
him or any sweat or dirt or anything
seriously just really now let's get down
and dirty starting my list off with
number 10 is a terrible terrible crime
thriller that I don't even understand
how this came about Alex Cross this
movie is directed by Rob Cohen and it
shows oh my word what a terrible
director this has some of the worst
shaky-cam
I have ever seen and possibly the worst
fight scene I've ever seen in my life
you can't tell what's going on the whole
movie is incomprehensible it has two
actors who are actually trying really
hard to give good performances Tyler
Perry and Matthew Fox and I can't really
blame them in particular for how bad
this movie came out the direction and
this
script are so awful and these actors and
the direction everything clashes to make
this just an absolute hilariously bad
movie because these actors are trying so
hard to give performances but because of
how bad the movie is turning out it just
becomes laughable at number 9 I have a
movie that when I first saw it I was
like this is going to be like the worst
movie of the year for a long time but I
actually saw eight films I like even
less since then This Means War it's
directed by Mick G and this is a movie
that just was maddening to watch each
character in this movie is so horrific
Lee dumb that you just you don't
understand why any of them are being the
way they are it's the kind of movie that
people go to and they're like hey that
was a pretty entertaining movie and then
like two months later like so remember
that movie This Means War and like what
movie oh yeah that movie yeah it was a
movie but when I saw it I just could not
stand how stupid and idiotic each
character in this movie was and how
poorly done the film was it just all
looked so fake and everything was just
glossed over with this Hollywood sheen
of idiocy at number eight we have a
movie that some people said I was too
unfair with it was a movie that was
supposed to be stupid and you're just
supposed to have fun with it and I get
if you like these movies I don't
underworld awakening actually enjoyed
the first underworld film I went back
and watched that movie after having seen
this one even though I couldn't stand
this movie and it was actually not bad
it had a sense of realism to it and it
was fun and it had some good action
sequences directed by Len Wiseman but
this movie was just a giant video game
movie literally almost every time a
character would go into a room of some
kind the electricity would be
malfunctioning in which he'd seen like
the lights were flashing on and off and
you're like you know that doesn't
improve your movie pal why are you doing
that it's one of those things where
you're watching you maybe don't think
about it but as soon as you notice it
you cannot stop noticing that every time
they're in a scene where there's
electric lights the electric lights on
and off and that's just a little nitpick
it's just such a stupid movie where the
script is just tied together with some
guy was like here's here's the script
for underworld just go make it because
they all make the exact same amount of
money back and make their budget back at
number seven we have one of the dumbest
titles of the year
the house at the end of the street
seriously who named the movie that I
want to know and why is Jennifer
Lawrence in this movie why is such a
talented actress in this movie at all
another movie that is just dumb I mean
are you seeing a trend here and when I
say that I don't mean like as movie was
dumb I mean it is really dumb like the
scripts for these movies are so bad it
has weird twists in it characters that
are that just they're just they're
they're just there to be the girl in the
horror movie or the guy in the horror
movie and it's not scary and that's the
biggest problem with this movie when you
make a horror movie and it's not scary
you've basically failed at everything
you're trying to do and number six we
have another film that kind of reminds
me of the underworld thing it's a film
that comes off very videogame s this
one's actually based off of a video game
and it's a film that a lot of people
were like it's just it's dumb but
whatever I'm sorry I cannot forgive
Silent Hill revelation for being
freaking awful besides the fact there
really is no thrills to this movie no
suspense no real scares it has such an
idiotic screenplay where nothing ties
together nothing in this movie actually
makes sense and you're like what what
like why are certain things happening
why are these characters doing this
right now
what's carrie-anne moss doing in this
movie with all those white makeup why in
the world is Malcolm McDowell in this
movie only to be in there for like two
seconds then he turns into a giant beast
it's like every single thing in this
movie just comes off so horrible the
performances were terrible the scares
were predictable it was gross in a bad
way it wasn't like ooh that was creepy
it was just disgusting I played the
first Silent Hill game and it scared the
crap out of me and it was legitimately
scary this movie and even the one before
it no and just an unnecessary sequel in
every way it actually was a sequel it
wasn't a retelling and because it was a
sequel and because it tried to tie into
the first film so many things in this
movie made absolutely no sense at number
5 we have a film that you probably
forgot I even reviewed because no one
saw this movie and it's a movie that I
understand why some people semi enjoyed
it for the most part this movie got
mediocre reviews but I just for some
reason this movie hit me on the exactly
wrong day on the wrong level and I just
could not stand sparkle I know it's
weird for me to hate on this movie
because unfortunately Whitney Houston
passed away I said in my review that she
was the best part of the movie and I
wasn't just saying that because of the
fact that she had passed away I meant it
she was the best part in that movie and
the only thing I actually enjoyed I
found this to be a melodramatic Lifetime
movie that had like Oprah Winfrey's
signature all over it I guess that's the
best way I can describe this movie
everything about this movie felt so
cliched the singers who just got famous
or what are they gonna do cocaine of
course because everybody who becomes a
famous singer eventually does cocaine in
the movies that's just how it is
domestic de Beus that was portrayed so
poorly in this film that audience
members in my theater were laughing
because they thought it was supposed to
be comical couldn't stand this movie had
one good scene in it with Whitney
Houston singing a song that was it and
number four we have the third and final
film on my list that I grew up into a
category underworld silent hill
revelation and now resident evil
retribution it's a sequel to this
videogame esque thing and it has to have
a real of some kind
revelation retribution reloaded
revolutions how many of these titles are
we going to get want want Paul WS
Anderson is one of my least favorite
directors working today not because he's
like an offensive man or anything but
because all of his movies are supremely
hideous in the worst possible ways and
you can just tell this movie is it 100%
cash grab but nothing else because as I
broke down in my original review these
movies all make back their budget and
more so and they just keep making them
because it is a money generating
franchise for Hollywood I'm a huge fan
of the Resident Evil games and I would
love to see a legitimate Resident Evil
movie that actually pays homage to the
games in a good way this is not that
movie
now we're starting to get serious here
number three the apparition oh my god
what a horrible movie that was Crabbe
that movie was a piece of garbage if you
saw my original review you saw that I
broke down the fact that this movie is
just a giant marketing ploy and lie the
entire ending of the film was spoiled in
the trailer and the entire marketing
ploy of the movie that you have to
believe in the ghost for it to attack
you but as long as you don't believe in
it it won't attack you yeah that's not
in the movie
hmmm it's not in the movie at all it has
nothing to do with the film the entire
marketing of this movie was based on a
lie to take your money from you
basically the whole movie is a girl in
her underwear wandering through hallways
reacting to noises and there's nothing
there and it is the most unscary
horror film of the year horrible in
every single way now at number two we
have possibly my most controversial pic
I suppose because this is once again a
movie just like Sparkle that got
mediocre reviews it didn't get good
reviews but even the bad reviews were
like yeah whatever it's there but for
some reason this movie just touched me
on the wrong nerve I could not stand the
Three Stooges no one really liked this
movie per se but a lot of people were
like it's not that bad I don't
understand why you hate it so much I'll
tell you why to me even though this
movie may be more well made than some of
the other films on this list it was just
so freakin annoying to me this movie was
like having three of Jar Jar Binks in
one movie just reacting and wandering
around the city and LU Mesa like that oh
these are like Sofia Vergara Mesa want
to touch that but Oh seriously I
couldn't stand this movie it annoyed me
and that's why it's my number two ok
guys looking back on 2012 there was no
competition absolutely no competition my
number one pick worst movie of the year
the movie that I just I couldn't stand
watching I wanted to just not watch it
anymore so many times throughout this
movie piranha 3 double D just the worst
freaking piece of absolute dog shit on
the planet like it's so it's just so bad
everything in this movie it's just like
what when your movie has a scene in
which a piranha swims up a woman's
vagina and decides to take a nap there
and then later while she is having sex
with her boyfriend decides you know what
I'm just going to wake up now and bite
off this guy's penis your movies
horrible if it has time and you can
argue that this movie is trying to be so
bad that it's good and that's exactly
what it's doing but it doesn't under
and what that is this movie has moments
words trying to be legitimately scary
where it's trying to be legitimately
sexy in some way where it's trying to be
gross and the only thing this movie does
successfully is piss everyone off it's a
movie that doesn't understand what it is
and it is so bad at doing what it's
trying to do the only positive thing
about this piece of garbage is the fact
that they released it on iTunes the same
day was released in theaters so I could
rent it and I didn't have to leave my
home I was so tempted to turn off that
computer so many times didn't I watched
it I mean for goodness sake David
Hasselhoff running in slow motion with
the Baywatch thing going on he did that
in 2004 in the spongebob movie it was
old eight years ago it was old before
the Spongebob movie came out it's not
funny anymore dude it's not funny at all
piranhas three double D you are the
worst piece of crap released in 2012
congratulations guys sorry I get a
little I get a little bit of a temper
you know in these movies
well guys all in all I actually enjoyed
the year of 2012 in film there was a lot
of really good gems these ones I
mentioned not so much if you disagree I
understand because you're going to
because this is my chance to just be
completely biased and offer my own
opinion nevertheless thanks a lot for
watching guys let me know what are your
picks and as always if you like this
video then you can click right here and
get stuck my next
Oh